Okay.
Let’s start.
Hello everyone.
Greetings.
Good evening or good morning.
Steve, I wanted to offer the difference
between paper and electronic books
as the topic for today’s discussion.
However, in the process of preparation
I understood that…
I will also be asking questions about books
and the Internet.
So, we are counterpoising books
and the Internet. All right?
Okay.
I think it will be interesting for our viewers.
I’ve prepared several questions.
The first one is:
Steve, what is reading?
What is your view on reading?
What does it mean?
What is reading?
I think reading is the most efficient way of…
How to say it?
Communication?
Sharing?
No, not communication. I think talking
is the best way of communication.
But…
[Reading is the best way] to learn something.
Of course, one can learn from experience.
It can teach us a lot.
In the end, it’s our experience
that helps us learn something.
But it’s impossible
to gain experience in everything.
Through reading, we can partake
in many situations and experiences.
I’m sorry, my Russian is…
I haven’t spoken Russian for a long time.
For instance, when I’m reading a book…
Let's say it's a 19th century novel.
I cannot personally experience
life in the 19th century,
but I can do this via the book.
Let’s say I’ve bought a computer.
How to use a computer?
I can look it up on Youtube.
But if I have the choice between
watching a video and reading, I prefer reading.
It is faster, and I can re-read it
whenever I want to.
It is convenient, efficient, and economical…
- Economical?
- Yes.
In my view, it is the most…
We have computers
and various other devices.
However, the very idea of reading
and writing...
I can communicate something to you via reading.
- Pass something to me.
- Yes.
This is fantastic.
The very fact that I’m reading,
and all these countless letters
turn into something meaningful…
To me, this is an amazing way of communication,
teaching and…
education.
- Education.
- Yes.
This is the most efficient means of education.
Besides, reading gives you pleasure.
People who love poetry, novels,
or love reading history books, like myself…
I’m reading books on the history of Central Asia.
I can…
- You can learn a lot from them.
- I can learn a lot from them. It’s efficient.
Reading is sacred.
It’s a great thing.
Both in Russia and Canada,
some people are poor readers.
Your level of reading is the main indicator
of the amount of success in your life.
Statistically, people who are passionate readers…
not all, but many of them
tend to be more successful professionally,
academically etc.
Every country has about 20% of people
who don’t read that well…
We say “don’t read too much.”
I’ve got you, Steve.
With your permission, I will quote
philosopher Andriy Baumeister.
He is very popular in Ukraine now.
When asked about reading, he said, “As we read,
we are deciphering symbols,
which requires concentration.
Reading is the art of deciphering signs.
One can fulfill his or her potential if he or she
has the codes to these sign systems.
May I ask your opinion about this?
I am especially interested in it,
because you read in several scripts,
including Persian, Arabic, hieroglyphs etc.
It would be interesting
to hear your opinion,
since you can view it from
standpoints of various sign systems.
Alphabets, like Cyrillic or Latin ones,
are sign systems.
Arabic is also an alphabet,
even though it’s a bit complicated.
And then there are hieroglyphs…
To me, these are systems of writing
you have to adjust yourself to.
Our brain has the system for construction of…
a model, or patterns.
We have this word. Patterns.
We can do this with Chinese hieroglyphs
as well as with Latin alphabet.
Of course, the more we use a particular sign system,
the more comfortable we get.
I can read Latin script better than Cyrillic one,
even though Cyrillic is not that complicated.
Still, I can read Polish, although my Polish
is worse than my Russian.
Cyrillic alphabet is more complicated to me…
Arabic and Chinese are even more difficult.
It depends on how much you’ve read
in this sign system before.
You have to let your brain get used to it,
and your brain will gradually adjust,
regardless of whether it’s Latin, Korean,
Cyrillic, or Chinese.
In fact, we didn't read in the first hundreds of
thousands of years of our existence as animals.
And now we are capable of doing it.
The fact that our brain has this ability nowadays
is a huge step forward.
A great event in our development as…
As living beings.
As species.
Okay, moving forward to the next question.
Do you think there is any difference between
reading paper and electronic books?
Do you regard reading exclusively paper books
as your ultimate goal?
I prefer reading paper books.
When I’m reading for pleasure, for instance,
in English, French, Russian etc.,
where at least 95% of words
are familiar to me. It's a minimum.
If every page contains more than
5 unfamiliar words,
it is not pleasant, and I don’t like it.
Even if it does not impact my understanding,
it is still annoying.
I don’t know what this word means.
This is why, when I read in the languages
I’m not fluent in,
I prefer reading on my iPad,
which allows to search for words or phrases
and listen to their pronunciation.
For instance, stresses in Russian or
pronunciation in Arabic,
where spelling has nothing to do
with pronunciation.
Reading electronic books on iPad
has many advantages.
However, reading is reading.
I love paper books...
Currently, we are unable to travel
due to Covid.
But whenever I’m traveling,
I prefer the iPad.
The iPad instead of paper books?
Right, because I don’t want to…
carry two or three suitcases of books.
I love reading. If I'd carried suitcases
of books with me,
and then bought more books in Kyiv or wherever,
my luggage would've been very heavy.
This is why iPad is very convenient.
I can buy any book instantly.
When I find an interesting book on the Internet,
I can buy it in English, Russian, or any other language
and start reading it.
This is very convenient.
However, reading for the sake of reading
is better when it’s a hard copy.
Paper books, then. Okay.
Why do we even need paper books
in the information era?
Let me explain.
In the 1990s, at least in the post-Soviet countries,
many teachers and scholars predicted
that books will become obsolete and that,
instead of reading books,
people of the future will watch videos
or listen to audios,
that is, receive information via different channels.
Nevertheless, as we see, books are doing just fine.
What are the explanations, in your opinion?
I think that we need books,
because in today’s life,
there are many… distractions.
Distractions, distractions.
Of course, there are both advantages
and disadvantages.
We can instantly look something up
or find out what happened.
There are countless distractions, that’s right.
However, when you sit down and start reading a book,
it’s only you, the book, and its content.
You find yourself in another world,
in a different situation, and you can…
Instead of sitting there, you are already
in a different universe.
You cannot click on a link.
It’s just a book, and you have to read it.
This is why I think books are irreplaceable.
Of course, there are videos, iPads, whatever.
There will be artificial intelligence
or something else, I don’t know.
Still, reading paper books
is a crucial activity.
In my view, we absolutely need it.
After several years of studying
a foreign language with Lingq,
I’m still impressed
by the fact that…
Studying with Lingq always implies reading.
I feel that, in the course of the past years,
Lingq has helped me concentrate better.
Reading helps me concentrate
and develops my imagination,
because, as you’ve mentioned,
reading a book helps you escape from reality
and travel to a different era.
As for me, it’s an interesting
thought that, on the Internet,
knowledge is always fragmented.
A little bit here, a little bit there.
In its turn, a book, especially a massive one,
offers you a narrative.
There are no distractions,
you cannot click anywhere,
and you embark on this long,
concentrated journey.
This is my view.
Yeah, I agree.
After I read a book, I look at my library
and remember it with pleasure.
It’s a great pleasure.
I love books.
As for studying languages,
I’m not eager to read books with
numerous unfamiliar words.
This is why…
- It’s annoying.
- Yeah.
This is why… I want… how do you say…
Increase my level in order to be able
to read paper books.
From your experience, how many…
I know this number would differ
from language to language,
but how many words should there be
in your passive vocabulary
so that you could read paper books?
A lot. A lot.
This depends…
You know, in Lingq, we read all the dictionary forms
of the word.
For Russian, it might be about 60 thousand words.
For English, it’s 40 thousand or so.
I don’t know, but it’s a huge number.
A whole lot of words.
For instance, a person
who knows Slovak language
can read in other
Slavic languages as well.
He or she can guess the meaning
without actually knowing the language.
- That’s right.
- Yeah.
Someone who knows Italian can read Spanish.
In order to read Russian, someone who knows
another Slavic language
would need a lot… A lot of words.
Okay.
Steve, don’t you think that…
Firstly, people tend to read less nowadays
than 30 years ago.
If we take the case of Canada,
do people still attend public libraries?
Are public libraries or bookshops with paper books
still popular?
I can’t say for sure.
Libraries are popular.
People attend libraries, and there are numerous
activities surrounding them.
People read, attend meetings, discussions,
and do many other things.
Libraries are great, they are very good.
As for bookstores, unfortunately,
there are enormous chains…
- We say ‘networks.’
- Yeah, networks.
Small bookstores don’t exist anymore.
Especially now, with the COVID situation,
there are few of them left.
There are some in Vancouver,
but I rarely go there.
Only if it’s absolutely necessary to buy something,
I go to the bookshop.
But I wouldln’t… I forgot the word.
Nevertheless, people still visit bookstores.
A year ago, many people used to go there.
I mean big bookshops,
like the three-storeyed ones.
They have cafes, tables…
But these are chain bookstores.
I think it’s the same in Ukraine, isn’t it?
Well, statistics says that we read
less than we used to.
Especially children.
Since I’m a father now, I know that many
parents are struggling
to accustom their children
to books instead of this.
This is a huge issue.
Do you think people will read more in the future?
Will there be a rollback to books?
Or will gadgets and virtual reality prevail?
First of all, one should be able to read
in order to use the iPhone.
It requires a little bit of reading.
I see that my grandchildren…
I have five grandkids.
They do read. All of them.
Whenever I buy them books, they read them.
Sometimes it’s hard copies,
sometimes it’s Kindle.
They do read,
as well as my son and my daughter-in-law.
Oh my God, I can’t even name
these relatives in Russian.
Daughter-in-law is probably “nevestka.”
The son’s wife.
The viewers will write the
correct word in the comments.
I’m not a specialist.
I think that in our society,
as well as in Ukraine,
there are people who read
and those who don’t read.
Some people love reading,
and others don’t read that much.
In my view, it all depends on the school.
It is crucial to help children
read well and fast.
Teaching children to read
is the most important thing.
Those people who haven't learned
to read well at school…
They can also be good workers.
I’ve worked with many people at our plants.
These people are very good with machinery,
and they aren’t keen readers.
You might call them professionally successful.
They have jobs.
However, according to statistics,
poor readers are less successful in life.
This is not a rule.
One can read a lot and be unsuccessful.
But the statistics are…
Steve, what do you think about reading several books
at the same time?
Do you read several books simultaneously
in different languages?
Yeah, it depends.
Right now, I’m…
I’m studying both Arabic and Persian.
Sometimes I read…
I have it here.
Сool!
Good.
It’s not my only Persian book.
Is it a handbook?
It’s a handbook.
[I also read] mini stories.
You have to read it again and again,
because you can’t memorize
everything from the first time.
Sometimes I read in Persian,
and sometimes in Arabic.
But I can’t do this with novels.
If I’m reading a novel or a history book,
I have to concentrate…
So you read in one language?
Yeah, one book.
Okay, this is interesting.
Does it matter to you whether
it’s fiction or non-fiction?
And does it matter for language learners as well?
It’s a matter of taste.
I prefer non-fiction.
To me, history is particularly interesting.
I’m studying Persian,
and I will read books on the history of Iran
or the history of Central Asia.
It’s all very interesting.
The influence of Iran on India…
On India.
Or the relations between Turkish peoples and cultures
and Iranian ones.
It’s all very interesting.
This is why I prefer reading…
I want to know lots of things.
And…
As for fiction, I prefer reading it in foreign languages.
I love Tolstoy.
Russians usually say, “Oh, you shouldn’t read it,
it’s written in old-fashioned language,
and it won’t help you.”
I totally disagree.
Me too.
I think that, when we are studying a language,
it’s a bit unreal to us.
The real one is our native language.
This is why I love reading about
19th century Russia.
Another language, another world,
era, and unfamiliar situations -
all of these are parts of the pleasure.
This is why I read fiction, like fairy tales etc.,
in French, Italian, or Russian.
It’s very…
In English, I only read non-fiction.
Okay.
I wanted to add that the novel
I’ve recently read in Italian
was written by an author from Barcelona.
I have to mention that the language of fiction
is amazing.
All these beautiful phrases, comparisons,
synonyms, and so on.
Besides, in fiction (we call it belle lettre)
there are always dialogues between the characters.
They communicate, and it’s quite helpful,
whereas non-fiction gives you
only facts, facts, and facts.
This is why it’s a matter of taste.
Okay, one more question…
Yes, I agree with you.
For instance, Tolstoy was among the first books
I’ve read in Russian.
It was “The Kreutzer Sonata.”
It’s a small book in comparison to “War and Peace.”
Subsequently, I’ve read his other books as well.
I love the way he uses the language.
Tolstoy is my favorite author.
Perhaps it’s not too original, but…
To me, it’s quite an easy and
comprehensible reading.
Unlike Dostoevsky, who is just… complicated,
Tolstoy is all about clarity and beauty.
I agree.
I love Chekhov as well.
Me too. Chekhov has some short stories,
which is good for language learners.
We don’t like reading lots of text.
His works are concise.
Short stories are very attractive to us
when we study a language.
Steve, there are the notions of ‘speed reading’
and ‘slow reading.’
I don’t know about Canada, but in Ukraine,
courses of ‘speed reading’ have been quite popular
for a while.
Reading quickly, diagonally,
consuming more information,
reading more books within shorter time etc.
What is your opinion about it?
Don’t we sacrifice the quality,
especially with regard to studying
a foreign language?
Should we go in for speed reading at all?
Well… I’ve tried it once.
I didn’t find it very efficient.
In my view, our reading speed increases
with the amount of books we read.
One should read a lot.
Maybe I’m old-fashioned, maybe I am.
But I don’t have patience, for instance,
to study mnemonics…
Mnemonics. It’s a method for memorizing things.
I’d better spend my time reading,
memorizing, forgetting, whatever.
If I see these words often,
I will memorize them.
For example, if I don’t read or speak Russian that much,
I will forget it.
If I start speaking or reading again,
it will improve…
This is why I rarely use speed reading, mnemonics,
or spaced repetition systems.
I’m not saying it doesn’t work.
It might work just fine.
I’ve tried spaced repetition, mnemonics,
and speed reading.
I’ve bought the books and blah-blah-blah…
But I haven’t… how do you say “continue.”
Yeah, you can say “I haven’t continued.”
I haven’t continued.
Yes, let’s put it this way.
Reading is a powerful tool for memorizing.
Why has humanity “forgotten” about it?
Why do people keep inventing
new systems, mnemonics etc.?
Reading exists for many centuries.
Have we forgotten about it?
I think it’s normal.
People will always invent new systems.
Systems for faster running,
for healthier eating…
People are coming up with all sorts of things.
However, reading will always exist.
For me, electronic books are very convenient.
They give us one more option
with regard to the situation.
For instance, I always read on my Kindle or iPad
while traveling,
because it’s convenient for studying languages…
a language.
It’s convenient.
One more thing:
we can use the same content in many ways,
in many…
Approaches, different ways.
Different approaches.
To me, reading paper books,
reading on my iPad,
listening to podcasts or audiobooks
are the available options.
If we use all these different types…
I don’t know,
some people prefer reading paper books,
others like electronic books
or use all of these [methods of reading].
Variety is good for us.
Variety is very beneficial for us.
Okay.
Variety, yes.
Steve, as you know, I popularize
Lingq and your method.
Different people who want to learn
various languages contact me.
Sometimes, when we start talking,
I find out that a person
has no habit of reading even in Russian.
They say, “I don’t read. I just don’t.”
Are there any ways to inspire people
and urge them to develop this habit?
Many people develop the habit of reading
after my course and the lessons at Lingq.
In the beginning, they are quite skeptical:
“No, I’d rather watch some videos,
series etc.
Reading is not for me.”
What would you say to those people?
First of all, with a video, you have to sit
and watch it for an hour straight.
This is why videos are not really
convenient or portable…
We say “portable”.
Many people dislike reading,
not only in Ukraine.
Maybe they hated reading at school,
I don’t know.
In order to learn languages… or a language…
Both “languages” and “language” are right.
Okay.
Reading is the most powerful tool [of learning].
The most powerful.
But…
We don’t…
One doesn’t begin with reading.
One begins with listening.
I can listen to something
while driving, walking, whatever.
Listening is the most portable and
convenient way of learning.
Today, we have mp3 and many other things.
I have a huge library on my iPhone,
in 15 languages or so.
Twenty years ago, every school or university
in Ukraine or Canada
had these huge linguistic libraries
with big tape recorders…
It’s called “lingaphonic cabinets.”
There were these big earphones…
Yeah. Nowadays, all you need are
Airpods and an iPhone.
Listening is the most portable way.
When I’m listening, I might understand
20, 30 or 50 percent,
but I’m eager to read.
I want to know what the content is.
While I’m listening, my brain is gradually
making some sense of it.
Reading is the fastest way of learning.
I listen, then I read it on Lingq
or my iPad.
I note the unfamiliar words,
and I begin to understand the foreign language.
But it all starts with listening.
Then, it’s building up or…
how do you say it?
Completed.
It gets completed with reading.
Probably I won’t be able to
understand everything,
even if I’ve read and listened to it
numerous times.
I’ve looked up the words,
noted them down and everything,
but I still don’t understand
what I’m listening to.
In this case,
I have to read it once more.
If I continue this…
virtuous circle.
Virtuous circle?
I only know “vicious circle.”
Let’s see… Virtue…
Let’s say “positive circle.”
Positive circle.
My brain will eventually get used to this word.
I think that, if people listen more,
this will arouse their curiosity.
“What am I listening to?”
It will push them to read…
It will encourage them to read more.
And I think that audiobooks are fantastic.
They are great.
In some languages, the quality and
quantity of audiobooks
are quite impressive.
It is not the case with Spanish.
But it is the case with Russian, French,
Swedish, or German.
I wanted to share something with you.
Last week, I’ve been preparing a course
for people who learn Turkish.
I’ve found out that Storytell website features
a huge, enormous library
in various languages, including Hindi,
Turkish, Arabic, Portuguese…
A lot of audiobooks.
I will share the link with you.
They have lots of books in good quality
and with good voice actors.
Of course, if I'm not fluent
in that language,
I need to have both the audiobook
and the electronic book
that can be downloaded by that link.
If I only listen to an audiobook in Arabic,
it will be a bit complicated.
Even if I understand 20 percent,
I am curious to know more.
This is why I’m eager to read.
Still, as I’ve said before, if a book contains
more than 5% of unfamiliar words,
I prefer reading an electronic version,
so that I can search the words etc.
Yeah, this is interesting.
Steve, can you name three books
in foreign languages
that have influenced you and your life
and became ingrained in your memory?
Both fiction and non-fiction are fine.
It’s hard to name such books…
Unfortunately, I don’t necessarily remember
the content of the book after I finish it,
even though I’ve liked it.
Lately, I’ve been reading books
on Russian influence in India.
This is very interesting.
Very interesting.
What is the title of the book?
Are you reading it in Persian?
It’s in English.
I don’t remember [the title].
When I’ve been studying Italian…
I love classics.
“I promessi sposi.”
When you say to an Italian,
“I’m reading I promessi sposi”,
it's the same as with Russian speakers
who studied Tolstoy at schools.
They don’t like [classical literature].
But I do.
I love reading Balzac in French.
- It’s a matter of taste.
- A matter of taste. Great.
Well, these are all the questions
I have for the moment.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, and excuse me for my Russian.
I will continue studying Persian, Arabic,
and then Turkish.
And then…
I just can’t revise…
I can’t spend a lot of time revising.
My Russian has become a bit worse.
But it will get better with time.
Steve, I would like to have such conversations
with you at least once a month.
Maybe we can pick some topics and discuss them…
Okay. It would be beneficial for my Russian as well.
This is also good for our audience,
because I’m telling a lot about you.
I think they will be interested to hear
your thoughts.
I would be delighted.
Great.
So I wish you a nice day.
Here, it’s already evening.
See you soon!
Okay. All the best.
So we’re wrapping up the video recording.
You’ll have the audio,
because I’ve been recording this conversation.
I’ll send you the second file as well.
Okay.
Thank you.